All right one other question.
I'm actually kind of
surprised you didn't ask me,
is what's this rollout nonsense?
>> I recognize that from
reading about T.D. Gammon.
>> How is it the same?
>> Because it's a word actually
comes from an understanding of how
people figure out which backgammon
boards are better or worse.
They actually, the rolling here is
the rolling of the backgammon dice.
>> That's not at all
what I was thinking.
>> What are you thinking?
>> Well, I was just thinking that
we have some roll out policy
which tells us what to
do when we're here.
And I said well let's just act randomly,
but
I don't know why that's
the right thing to do.
I mean, if I end up here and
I've got to do something we're trying
to get an estimate of this state, and
taking this particular action and
ending up in this state.
Why is that good or bad?
And the way you're going to do it is,
I'm going to say,
well I know how good it is to be here by
behaving randomly from that point on.
I mean, that'll give you probably an
underestimate of the true value, but it
would be nice if you could do something
that perhaps made a little more sense.
So people who have done work on MCTS
have often put some effort into,
well lots of things.
Being clever about this expansion,
keeping the right set of statistics,
kind of shoving their
expiration in very smart ways.
But other people have spent a little
bit of effort trying to figure out
can I come up with a better
policy besides behaving randomly?
That will help me to have a better
estimate of this particular q value.
And we can talk about I'm going to just
quickly talk about one by mentioning
something that we have already
talked about so far in this lesson.
Do you remember the command
you came up with Pac-Man?
>> It was like eat, eat, eat, avoid.
>> Right.
>> So like eat little dots,
eat big dots, eat ghosts, avoid.
>> Right, so I'm going to
point out that of those four.
Which I'll just call eat,
eat, eat, and avoid.
Which one of those is different?
>> So, I don't know.
The first one.
>> Eat?
>> Where you're eating big dots.
Yeah, or small dots.
Now I guess you want to say, avoid.
Because it's the word that's
different in the list.
>> Avoid is different, but it's
actually different in a different way.
Here we said, eat a little dot, eat a
big dot, eat a ghost, and avoid ghosts.
Remember when I said before that
temporal extraction
becomes goal extraction?
I'm going to claim that each
of these does have a goal.
One is to eat little dots.
One is the big dots.
And one is the little goblins.
But that when you execute the eat
small dot, it actually terminates.
At some point you eat a small dot.
And now you can move
on to the next thing.
At some point you eat large dot and
now you can move on to the next thing.
At some point you eat a goblin and
then you can move on to the next thing.
But avoiding goblins, avoiding ghosts,
that isn't really something that ends.
You're supposed to be
avoiding ghosts all the time.
>> I see.
Well, I guess it's sort of the negation.
I do understand how
that's different now.
So hitting the ghost
ends when you succeed.
Avoiding I want to say
ends when you fail.
[LAUGH] Right.
>> Right.
>> Like I'm avoiding the ghost
then said ooh.
I wasn't able to avoid the goals.
Right, so in fact these things have sort
of goals, they have success conditions.
They end when you succeed.
Avoid is a little different.
It sort of ends only when you fail.
You can never succeeded avoiding goals
you can only fail at it in some sense.
Whereas here there a sort of finite
time in which you achieve your goal and
that success.
So it turns out that when you ask
people to come up with these kinds of
options, they actually come up
with things that look like this.
Lots of goals with lots
of success metrics.
But they also come up with things
where you can sort of only fail.
We actually have a word for that and
they're called constraints.